bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission 7 8
week-end émission consacrée aux loisirs
aux idées de sorties dans le département
tout de suite le sommaire de votre
émission musique un concert de noël est
programmée ce samedi à 20 heures 30 dans
l'église saint-victor de guyancourt pour
nous parler de cet événement nous
recevrons dans quelques instants
christian cottin le président de
l'association coeur viva voce et la chef
de choeur catherine lautier théâtre le
spectacle pétanque et sentiments 4
festival d'avignon deux mois molière de
versailles est programmée ce vendredi et
ce samedi au théâtre du grenier à
bougival les détails dans cette édition
cinéma la responsable jeune public des
yeux d'elsa de saint-cyr-l'ecole marine
pool nous présentera son coup de coeur
de la semaine va nous parler du film
avril et le mon truc et un ciné goûter
sur ce dessin animé sera organisée ce
samedi dans le cinéma
et puis en fin d'émission l'agenda
sportif du week-end dans le département
il y aurait notamment du rugby avec le
match plaisir contre maisons laffitte
nous commençons ce magazine par de la
musique le coeur viva voce se produira
ce samedi à 20 heures 30 dans l'église
saint-victor de guyancourt pour un
concert spécial noël pour nous parler de
cet événement nous recevons sur ce
plateau christian collin le président de
l'association coeur viva voce et la chef
de choeur catherine gauthier bonjour
alors tout d'abord est ce que vous nous
présentez la chorale viva voce le coeur
viva voce était anciennement dénommée la
chorale croq'notes qui existe depuis 32
ans est composé de 50 choristes amateurs
et donne un certain nombre de concerts
par an essentiellement juin et les
concerts de noël qui ont toujours
beaucoup de succès donc des choristes
amateurs
quand on est amateur toujours mauvais
tous plus ou moins plus ou moins
professionnels puisque on a quand même
quand même des solistes qui sont
d'excellents solistes et il ya 4 4
pupitres évidemment dans ce dans ce
coeur et ce sont essentiellement des
saint quentinois dans la chorale oui
essentiellement il ya quelques personnes
qui viennent du territoire d'un
territoire au toc 100 m saint quentin
mais la plupart sont de guyancourt
mokili où les environs et donc plusieurs
représentations sont programmées dans la
vie oui on fait en général
concert à noël et concerts en fin
d'année
et on fait deux concerts cette année à
noël ce week-end donc un enduit en cours
et un à buc dimanche et les concerts de
juin seront 1 / guyancourt et l'autre à
l'occasion du mois molière à versailles
et donc il ya des différences planète
entre le la représentation de noël et la
représentation de l'été oui le programme
est totalement différent à noël on
essaye de cibler plus tôt un répertoire
sur noël avec
quelques extraits ce donc cette année on
fait en plus des extraits du messie de
haendel qu'on a déjà produit il ya deux
ans on a
donc des chants de noël traditionnels
ont fait des extraits de bach
voilà c'est un petit peu
un petit melting-pot de musique
différente au mois de juin ce sera plus
une oeuvre ce sera totalement une oeuvre
différente et une seule oeuvre ce sera
le stabat mater de karl jenkins 4-1
contemporain et donc on fera ça
accompagné d'un pianiste au mois de juin
donc c'est un répertoire assez large a
cédé répertoire assez large mais on
essaye pourquoi avoir choisi justement
de proposer un répertoire large
on essaye de toucher un petit peu à tout
ce qui se fait dans la musique classique
lyrique
donc on fait don des carnot peyrat ont
fait des oeuvres on a fait le requiem de
mozart récemment
qu'on va refaire d'ailleurs au mois de
mars aussi sur dans les yvelines
voilà on essaye de toucher un petit peu
tout du tout le style de musique
classique qu'on peut faire et donc ce
n'est pas la première représentation
qu'on fait
à liancourt un prêt du tout où chaque
année nous faisons plusieurs
représentations survie en cours
essentiellement dans l'église
saint-victor puisqu'elle a une
acoustique qui est excellente et depuis
qu'elle a été en fait c'est un très très
beau bâtiment et chaque année nous avons
notre notre concert de noël et on a on a
il ya beaucoup de spectateurs qu'ils
aériennes les qui a oui il ya un public
qui est très très très fidèle au concert
de noël parce que c'est très festif et
on participe les parties les spectateurs
participent aussi certains champs et
donc il reste quelques places pour le
concert
oui certes ce n'est pas l'église est
assez grande donc on accueille on arrive
on n'a jamais été à la totalité de
l'église même si elle est quand même pas
mal rempli et donc pour contenter les
spectateurs vous travaillez actuellement
d'arrache-pied
vous avez travaillé d'arrache-pied oui
oui on a travaillé dessus on répète tous
les mardis soir à guyancourt et donc on
a une répétition générale ce soir
et puis les concerts pour demain mais on
est prêt et quel est le tarif du couple
pour une soirée comme comme celle-là
elle reprend les adultes c'est 12 euros
et pour les enfants c'est 8 euros
jusqu'à l'âge de 12 ans puisque c'est un
c'est un cancer qui s'adresse aux
familles il ya beaucoup de chants
traditionnels et
mais c'est intéressant d'avoir aussi
bien les parents que les enfants et
combien de temps devrait durer le
concert où ça va à peu près une heure
une heure et quart une heure une heure
et quart du coup le programme ça ça va
s'enchaîner comment exactement
expliquez-nous tout bien écouter on va
enchaîner tous les morceaux que j'ai
prévu dans le dans le répertoire
on commence par des chants de noël on
on enchaîne par des extraits de bach on
continue par d'autres chants de noël et
on finit par des extraits du requiem de
messie de haendel pardon avec le célèbre
alléluia de haendel en finale
voilà les questions vous aimeriez que
les gens pensent de ce concert à la
sortie avant tout qu'ils soient heureux
qu'ils aient passé une bonne soirée et
qu'ils aient envie de revenir au
prochain concert on en fait on en fait
régulièrement
je pense que le concert de juin sera un
petit peu particulier puisque c'est un
compositeur contemporain et on aimerait
avoir un beau coup de pub lic alors
c'est pas du tout le même la même
approche le concert de noël
mais si l'on apprécié notre niveau de
chant je pense qu'ils soient intéressés
pour venir à ce ce concert de jeu en fin
d'année merci à vous d'être passé sur ce
plateau je le rappelle le concert de
noël du coeur à viva voce est programmée
ce samedi à 20h30 à l'église saint
victor de mieux en cours coup de
projecteur à présent sur une exposition
je vous emmène désormais dans la galerie
de noël du trianon palace de versailles
l'hôtel de luxe est associée à la maison
deyrolle pour célébrer la magie des
fêtes de fin d'année une exposition en
accès libre jusqu'au 7 janvier le
reportage est signée sephora namani et
patrick jacques de dixmude un peu de
rêve et de féerie pour célébrer la magie
de noël
c'est dans cet esprit qui a été décoré
la galerie du trianon palace versailles
par la maison deyrolle l'association de
deux maison plus que centenaire qui
nourrissent les mêmes valeurs
cette année on voulait donner un crème
un peu plus féeriques donné la portière
était tant aux adultes qu'aux enfants
pour redécouvrir un peu la nature
association avec des rôles n'est venue
de par notre enfance par les souvenirs
que nous avions des
des plaques d'affiché de dessin deyrolle
ainsi que des livres qu'il produit
transformé en cabinet de curiosités la
galerie accueille des animaux
merveilleux naturalisé par la maison
deyrolle papillons multicolores pendent
le haut à renard zèbres et ours blancs
des animaux tous décédés de mort
naturelle en zoo une façon de donner une
deuxième vie et de porter à la
connaissance du public des animaux qui
peut être un jour disparaîtront comme
les ours polaires deyrolle est une
société sciences naturelles side ct qui
porte la nature là où elle est c'est à
dire où elle doit tête c'est à dire dans
un souci de préservation d'observation
de compréhension et tout l'esprit de
cette exposition c'est de montrer que
dont la sublime beauté il ya en même
temps une très très grande fragilité
cette fragilité de la nature il faut et
si justement de l'intégrer dans notre
conscience pour être des acteurs de
cette préservation
cette exposition éphémère est en accès
libre jusqu'au 7 janvier
l'occasion de découvrir un univers
chimérique dans un très bel endroit
nous allons à présent parler théâtre le
spectacle pétanque et sentiments 4
festival d'avignon deux mois molière de
versailles plus de 250 représentation
est programmée ce vendredi et ce samedi
au théâtre du grenier à bougival pour
nous parler de cette représentation nous
recevons sur ce plateau bernard pinet à
comédien acteur vous a notamment joué
dans le rôle du fameux contrôleur du
fisc lucien cheval dans le dîner de cons
au théâtre jusque là pas d'erreur
mise en scène par pierre mondy mise en
scène temps qui rebondit alors tout
était en place pour ce soir oui oui je
viens du théâtre là je vais retourner
bien sûr ça se présente très bien soyez
rassurés donc la lumière tout tout tout
fonctionne
vous avez trouvé en lumière et decker
les accessoires sont en place et des
corps est installé nous vous attendons
et est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter
le spectacle pétanque et sentiments oui
bien sûr c'est un spectacle qui rentre
dans le cadre des 3 unité de temps de
lieu et d'histoire il y à un seul père
le comédien mais quinze personnages qui
existent par la magie du verbe et le jeu
du comédien
c'est un spectacle populaire mais non
populiste qui nous concerne tous
puisqu'il est question d'amour
uniquement d'amour entre les jeunes des
moins jeunes les anciens les animaux les
hommes politiques des animaux politiques
et piano plein d'autres choses qui qui
anime notre société donc vous êtes seul
sur scène vous interpréter un personnage
mais par contre il y a quinze
personnages en fait qu'ils aient acquis
agi interagissent avec vous oui on t'a
fait donc un animal un charge un petit
chien satellite iti parce qu'il vient
d'ailleurs et qu'il est le lien entre le
patron de ce bistrot qui n'a pas de nom
de danse et prennent vie autour de
retour de vous tout à fait il existe peu
ils entrent ils sortent c'est la
clientèle de ce petit bistrot perdu dans
dans ce coin un peu abstrait du delà du
midi du midi qui est écologiquement
correspond à un écho méditerranéen donc
universelle et plein de choses s'y
passent
et c'est ce qui fait peut-être le charme
de ce spectacle le fait que vous soyez
seul sur scène
le charme et l'intérêt de ce spectacle
c'est son contenu c'est le sens et les
valeurs qui colportent qui nous concerne
tous puisque elle sont universelles dans
le sens le plus basique du mot il ya de
l'humour tout le temps tout le temps
mais il ya aussi de la tristesse de
l'émotion l'au delà est évoqué la vie la
mort puisque la mort fait partie de la
vie le voile est levé sur sur plein de
choses qui interpelle l aventure humaine
et donc c'est un spectacle de théâtre un
petit peu à l'ancienne on peut on peut
le dire à tout à fait à l'ancienne dans
le sens traditionnel du mode en trois
actes en trois actes bien sûr et dans le
la mission intrinsèque et au talent du
maître du théâtre qui est celle de
transmettre de transmettre des messages
et les expériences qui doivent être
utiles pour le présent et le futur
parlez nous un peu de votre personnage
il est il est le patron de ce bar il est
arrivé dans ce village par le plus grand
des hasards à un moment où il voulait se
retirer pour devenir moine boulistes en
attendant que le veau d'or finissent à
l'abattoir et laly a rencontré une femme
qui est devenue la maman de son fils
temps les parties elle est décédée en
lui donnant la vie et il a donc élevé
sept enfants dont ce village qui n'est
jamais nommé dans ce bistrot qui
pourrait être le café de la vie où se
croisent tout le contenu de l'existence
il aime passionnément sa clientèle
il est à son service il l'écouté il lui
répond et c'est un personnage fort en
caractère
il ya beaucoup de cas il a beaucoup de
caractère ce personnage
il a beaucoup de caractère oui il est
bien là il existe c'est un cosmo
tellurique qu'est les pieds sur terre et
la truffe dans les étoiles
et comment elles expliquent ce succès de
pétanque et sentiments gelé 10 250
représentations un peu plus que 250
représentations
comment il explique ce succès est ce que
finalement c'est un spectacle qui parle
à tout le monde tout à fait il concerne
tout le monde le succès c'est le tome
dame à savoir que la répétition générale
a eu lieu au théâtre michel à paris
la centième a eu lieu
à la huchette là on est assez fiers
parce que dans le livre dans la deuxième
édition du livre qui est sorti en 2014
il y à là la photo de la huchette avec
la cantatrice la leçon et pétanque et
sentiments quand on connaît l'histoire
de la huchette et de ionesco on peut
être qu'un peu fier de cela
ensuite quatre festival d'avignon deux
mois molière aucun soutien médiatique si
ce n'est vous merci télévision à nous
avoir reçu jusqu'à saluer c'est avec
grand plaisir et nous reviendrons
toujours avec loisirs et nous lançons un
appel à l' écoute aux autres médias mais
depuis ces dernières années vous êtes la
seule chaîne à nous avoir reçus nous en
sommes reconnaissants et ce spectacle je
l' ai vu personnellement c'est un
spectacle qui mêle humour mélancolie
dérision finalement c'est des tabous
comme vous l'avez dit de la vie en fait
c'est ça c'est ça vous recherchez les
thèmes de la vie c'est l'histoire de
l'être humain sur cette petite planète
histoire confuse mystérieuse riche
étrange qui pourrait éventuellement bien
se finir mais ça dépend que de nous et
cela n'est pas gagné et on pensait que
ce spectacle peut concerner tout le
monde sait d'ailleurs qu'on peut venir
en famille on peut venir avec sa copine
son copain ça peut concerner vraiment
tout le monde pour devenir urgent de
voir vaincu spectacle pour une bonne et
simple raison c'est que nous l'avons
vérifié depuis plusieurs années que nous
leur présentons un peu partout en france
nous avons eu des des enfants des
adultes les parents des anciens des
seniors les seniors se régale aussi
particulièrement avec ce spectacle
oui il concerne tout le monde vous
pouvez tout et tous venir en confiance
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner envie
en 30 secondes de venir voir votre
spectacle en 30 secondes
papus c'est très simple ça serait
entretenir une lacune culturel et un
vide théâtrale en ne venant pas
découvrir pétanque et sentiments ce soir
à 20h45 au théâtre de bougival
mais bonne nouvelle on se joue aussi
dont joue aussi demain soir donc son
look
ce soir on peut revenir devant tout à
fait ils résident peut venir de
représentation si c'est possible je joue
je vous encourage à le faire tarif est à
combien les tarifs les plus chères sont
à 15 euros mais ça descend jusqu'à 7
euros la palette est large
merci à vous d'être passé sur ce plateau
bernard fini c'est un plaisir de vous
recevoir
on passe maintenant à notre rubrique
littérature direction à présent le pavé
du canal comme chaque semaine la
librairie vous fait découvrir un nouveau
roman cette semaine zoom sur les
commandes les communards de parts aux
éditions vents d'ouest une bd sur la
place des femmes de répand dans la
commune en 1871
on regarde aujourd'hui je vous présente
un double album du scénariste lupano
donc ça s'appelle les communarde donc
lupano on lui doit entre autres un océan
d'amour et puis les vieux fourneaux le
livre fournit d'ailleurs il ya un le
troisième tome qui va sortir la cour
encore novembre donc là aujourd'hui je
vais vous parler surtout de ses deux
albums il y aura un troisième qui
viendra conclure cette trilogie sur la
place des femmes dans la révolution
socialiste qui a eu lieu à paris donc en
donc le premier album se situe juste
avant l'insurrection de paris c'est donc
c'est une histoire d'une petite fille et
une relation avec sa maman donc quelle
place va voir sa maman dans cette
révolution donc 1870 c'est la pénurie de
face à la famine à grande famine donc
voilà l'insurrection commence à monter
la révolution se met en place et là on
fait un ont fait un gros focus sur la
place des femmes et leur leurs positions
qu'elles ont prises durant cette cette
révolution donc le premier album va
traiter sur l'avant 1871 et le second
album en fait c'est durant
l'insurrection c'est une disciple de
marx qui a envoyé depuis londres à paris
pour un peu mettre de l'ordre et mettre
en marche ce mouvement féministe et pour
justement impliquer les femmes au plus
près de cette révolution
outre les très beaux dessins qui sont
totalement différentes donc en fait sur
chaque album
ça va être un dessinateur puis un second
dessinateurs sur le troisième ce sera
encore un autre dessinateur donc outre
ce
ce très beau dessin vraiment un très
beau très c'est surtout la place de la
femme dans cette révolution qui
finalement enfin déjà c'est une
révolution socialiste on parle dont on
parle très très peu et là surtout de la
place de la femme dans cette révolution
donc on voit que finalement elles ont
été vraiment actrice et est preneuse
d'ordre aussi sur sur tous les
événements qui ont pu avoir lieu durant
cette révolution on passe à présent
notre rubrique cinéma comme chaque
semaine un programmateur des civils nous
présente son coup de coeur aujourd'hui
nous avons le plaisir de recevoir en
plateau marine pool à responsable jeune
public du cinéma les yeux d'elsa de
saint-cyr-l'ecole bonjour alors
aujourd'hui votre coup de coeur est
destiné aux films avril et le mon truc
et on regarde la bande-annonce est
heureux on vous retrouve juste après
dans un monde privé d'innovation est
bloqué à l'âge de la vapeur des savons
disparaissent mystérieusement
je cherche mes parents
je vois bien dans ses achats semnoz pas
et ça ne parle pas c'est noël milk tu
devrais trouver
est ce que tu fais moi et je n'eusse
perdu 10 par an c'est ça je pourrais
aider tout cas pas d'idée échange de
salive déjà demi je vois qu'elle t'aime
bien
tu sais que chez qui on est oui tu peux
m'expliquer c'est pas vraiment le moment
ça fait aussi partie de votre numéro
surtout le mérite et il a raison et
c'est très dangereux je t'interdis une
fois à faire toute nue
et comment ne répond plus
quand je pense que je cherche mes
parents étaient surtout que je tombe
c'est bon vous avez fini ben pourquoi ce
film a retenu votre attention
à quoi sert votre coup de coeur alors
c'est un très bon film un très bon
dessin animé accessible vraiment tout
public
enfin voila c'est autant pour les les
enfants pour les pour les adultes il est
rythmé enlever c'est un vrai film
d'aventurés en même temps c'est un
univers très très original vous avez vu
avec la création graphique de jacques
tardi le dessinateur de bande dessinée
est un monde à la jules verne mais en
même temps avec des inventions vraiment
farfelues enfin voilà un film qui fait
plaisir et qui fait réfléchir et on voit
qu'il ya vraiment une recherche visuelle
et ressources dessin animé on voit que
c'est très travaillants mais oui ça a
été très très travaillé ils ont mis sept
ans pour faire le film
en commençant par voir les premières
recherches est effectivement donc toute
la patte graphique c'est cet art doute
les animateurs ont cherché à évidemment
à reproduire le style est là la patte de
tardi et puis tout les ans toutes les
inventions donc je parlais de jules
verne mais après ils ont amené aussi des
choses très original mais déjà la double
tour eiffel et puis après plein d'autres
le téléphérique paris berlin la méta
maison enfin la plainte de plein de
trouvailles assez farfelue puis la
représentation de paris et est vraiment
génial donc vous l'avez vu vous avez été
conquise
ah oui oui complètement oui donc là ça
va être
l'occasion donc l'issue de cette
projection demain de faire une animation
dessus pour un petit peu montrer
l'envers du décor sur la fabrication 20
l'univers du film et des grands acteurs
ont participé à ce film il ya mal
notamment marion cotillard et jean
rochefort
oui jean rochefort qui est très
reconnaissable dans le rôle du grand
père pops qui est vraiment qu'est
vraiment génial et marion cotillard
aussi qui prête sa loi comme en avril et
dans le rôle du chat darwin qui était
drôle ya aussi l'humour dans le film je
l'ait pas dit tout à l'heure c'est
philippe katerine donc apporter une
petite touche décalée personnage du chat
mon chat qui parle et donc vous avez le
projeté demain
wiland un ciné goûter demain donc à 14h
à l'issue de la projection ce samedi à
14 me alors d'abord je vais je vais
proposer un quiz donc je distribue un
quiz à faire avant donc avant le film et
à l'issue de la projection il y aura la
réponse en images avec des extraits et
enfin voila c'est l'idée de faire une
sorte de bonus dvd mais un sale et à ce
que tout le monde peut participer à ce
cd goûter oui oui oui oui c'est où s'est
ouvert à tous donc
donc on peut venir en famille y'a pas de
soucis oui oui tout à fait oui alors
c'est pas c'est pas un film qui est
destiné aux tout-petits mais bon à
partir de 5-6 ans sans problème
et quel est le tarif du coup pour c'est
un débouté un tarif unique pour toutes
nos animations c30 50 pour tout le monde
d'accord le message est passé merci
d'être passé sur ce plateau baring vous
et à bientôt on passe à présent aux
autres sorties de la semaine et
spectateurs étaient au micro de jérémy
quesada c'est un super feeling aventure
c'est l'histoire réelle de moby dick on
avance
raconter la trame mais c'est un super
film et il ya beaucoup d'humanité en
fait c'est un beau grand film d'aventuré
à l'ancienne je dirais avec de grands
sentiments
des effets spéciaux pas trop marqué ce
qui est appréciable de nos jours parce
qu'on en prend plein les yeux d'habitude
et franchement c'est vraiment un film
peut-être pas tout public parce que pour
les enfants c'est un peu violent mais
vraiment une belle surprise film est
touchant et
une sorte de spiritualité qui
travaillent un peu tout là toute
l'histoire
lellouche c'est vraiment quelqu'un dans
le cinéma x à part et je peux pas dire
et aucun de ces films qui m'a déplu
vraiment ses servants super six adoré de
le fond de l'histoire
l'interprétation forcément voilà la
musique tout on commence cette rubrique
sport part du rugby un match qu'il ne
faudra absolument pas rater pour plaisir
le prc reçoit dimanche à 15 heures
maison laffitte au stade robert barran
un derby qui s'annonce électrique
plaisir lutte pour prendre la première
place du classement à ris orangis et de
son côté maisons laffitte est bon
dernier du championnat et lutte pour sa
survie
vous l'aurez compris il devrait y avoir
du spectacle rendez vous samedi à 15
heures pour les soutenir
on passe au handball c'est peut être le
match de la dernière chance pour le ch
et néo promu cette saison en nationale 2
les hommes coachés par yannis norbert
sont dans le dur n'ont remporté qu'un
seul de leurs huit matchs disputés cette
saison
conséquence les chenilles un pointe à la
dernière place du classement
le match de ce dimanche s'annonce
également compliquée pour les yvelinois
il affronte saint nazaire sixième du
classement les supporters devront faire
beaucoup de bruit dans les tribunes pour
les pousser à se transcender
voilà pour les résultats pour les rendez
vous sportifs du week end c'est la fin
de six sept huit week-ends merci d'avoir
suivi je vous retrouve les mardi
prochain pour la 7 8 sport très bon
week-end sur tv fil 78